and I am fighting for my son of course
but it is bigger than Ross and bigger
than a website I think one website is by
far less dangerous than the government
trampling on our rule of law and the
Constitution I think that is very
alarming and to see it up close and
personal the way I am makes it very real
[Music]
hi I'm Nicolas be with reason TV and
today I'm talking with Lynn Albrecht she
is the mother of Ross Ulbricht who is
the defendant known as Dread Pirate
Roberts the alleged proprietor of Silk
Road he is going on trial in November
for what could be one of the most
important trials certainly of the web
and certainly of this year he is charged
with narcotics trafficking computer
hacking money-laundering running a
continuing criminal enterprise Lynn
thanks for talking to us oh my pleasure
your son has pleaded not guilty on all
charges that's correct
would you say you believe completely in
his innocence that he is not Dread
Pirate Roberts I do I believe in Ross
he's a man of his word and I do believe
in him in a way obviously your your
going to be predisposed to believing in
your son and believed in it his
innocence but one of the reasons we're
talking with you is because you become
an outspoken advocate of why this trial
matters to people who don't know Ross
Ulbricht to people who never use Silk
Road who have never bought legally or
illegally pot or any other kind of drug
let's talk a little bit about this and
some of the arguments that you and your
us as lawyers who are Joshua turtle and
Lindsey Lewis have talked about this
matter is because you believe it opens
the door for the censure of a free
internet can you talk a little bit about
that sure the prosecution relies very
heavily on something called transferred
intent and basically what that does is
makes one person responsible for the
intention and actions of another person
and in this case its website host is
responsible and in conspiracy with the
users of the site and the ultimate user
of the product I believe just by Nate
the fact that they are on the site and
Forbes Eric Goldman recently wrote about
this in Forbes and he said this is going
to put a chill on the Internet
because how can a website host know
what's every single thing that's going
on a site and a lot of them do kind of
know that there's illegitimate stuff
going on so this is kind of like if
you're running a site you know in it
there's a bunch of people that you know
start swapping you know prostitution
services or something as it stands now
for the most
part of your the web host and you're not
specifically party to that you're you
can't be charged with criminal activity
correct that's under Section 230 of the
Communications Decency Act so that's
like if you as an individual took one of
them to court in civil court they would
be immune however if the federal
government took them to court in
Criminal Court they would have no
protections whatsoever which joshua
rachel says creates a dangerous anomaly
and opens a crack in the door for
precedent to be set here because if ross
were convicted it he'd be the first
website host ever to be convicted for
the actions of the users of the site and
the federal government said in their
responses to the motions our laws are
expansive and adaptable especially when
it comes to the internet where does that
come from do you know the idea that the
Internet is you know somehow a looser
place for law enforcement than meatspace
well exactly and the Supreme Court just
made it clear that it is not that the
digital information falls under the
protections of the Constitution just
like anything else in the Reilly versus
California case which takes us into
illegal searches and seizures talk a bit
more about transferred in Tennessee how
that's playing out with Federal Express
as well yeah the Federal Express was
recently indicted for drug trafficking
because they are holding them
responsible for people using their
service to transport illegal
prescription drugs so the idea here I
mean the the idea that to bring it back
to the notion that this case matters
because it opens the door to a kind of
censoring of the market on the internet
but also a chilling effect is that
suddenly if you're a web host and you
can be held responsible for things
people are doing or saying on your
website you're in big trouble well I
mean it's and it's not only me saying it
you know Eric Goldman and his Forbes
article said you know why would someone
go take the chance and one thing to risk
your money it's another thing to risk
your freedom and it's not even an excuse
to say oh I didn't know it was going on
because you're supposed to know what's
going on according to the government and
I mean to be fair though Silk Road was
positing itself I mean it was selling
itself as a marketplace
of illicit and you know oftentimes
either gray market or black market goods
and services well from what I understand
and I didn't go on it I don't that much
about it really is that it initially was
an anonymous marketplace that was
consumer directed but yes of course
there were illicit things on there so
but the point is it's the principle
involved and the precedent that will be
set right so I'm not here to defend Silk
Road at all or drug use or anything but
what what our lawyers are saying is that
this opens up a dangerous little crack
in the door and well they're doing it
with FedEx I don't think anybody thinks
FedEx is it's really a pleasure yeah
yeah so okay another reason why you say
the case matters is that vague
allegation you know that it's built on
vague allegations that don't cite
specific crimes and so that violates the
fifth and sixth amendments talk a little
bit about how that plays out in this
case right they speak in very sweeping
generalities in the indictment which is
not in constitution of directly in
opposition of the Fifth Amendment and
due process which says allegations must
be specific and they talk about others
known and unknown a series of violations
or malicious software certain narcotics
laws without naming a specific one this
is void for vagueness according to the
courts this meet you have to cite
specific allegations otherwise these
allegations how do you defend yourself
against something vague and this goes is
is the government making the case that
well because this is internet-based we
don't have to be quite as exact or do
you think it's just sloppy prosecution
well actually our lawyers did try to get
some specifics out of them informally
before the motions and what they got
back was an email saying you have all
the specifics you need that was all the
explanation they gave they didn't say
why following up on that in a slightly
different
but related way there are Fourth
Amendment concerns that are raised here
about also kind of detailing giving
actual detailed specific understandings
of where certain types of evidence comes
from and and how it was found chuckle
and just recently your lawyer the
lawyers for Ross put in motions about
the Fourth Amendment saying that all of
this evidence should be you know
basically taken out talk a little bit
about that
okay sure first of all they have not
said how they found the Silk Road server
what methods they used this is required
and if you don't say how then how do you
even know the evidence wasn't fabricated
I mean or that's my question so they
need the the motions are saying you need
to tell us how you found the server if
they have a warrant we we don't know for
sure but that it's widely believed that
the server was in a foreign country
someone correct right yeah I believe
Iceland right so then there's the
question did you need a warrant there's
precedent for that in the Microsoft case
where the government had a warrant and
was able to go to a foreign server and
get the information but from what I
understand it's still required by the
Fourth Amendment
so basically part of the argument then
is that if the if the server was in a
foreign country and the government
somehow got into they got it and were
able to mirror it or basically take
everything off it that you know where is
the warrant for that or under what
circumstances did they get that
information exactly if it was procured
illegally then all the evidence deriving
from that is ended miscible and that's
pretty much I one would assume that's
the case right there it could be yeah
but there's also other violations for
instance there's 14 searches and
seizures in this case and there's more
than one that have no warrant but the
other issue is a warrant needs to be
specific as we're talking about and it
needs to be satisfied probable cause the
reason legitimate reason to go after it
here they're what call are called
general warrants where it's a fishing
expedition through all your your
property
and this is it unlimited rummaging
through everything hoping to find
something this is the same kind of
warrant that we had the American
Revolution over that Thomas Paine wrote
common sense about run its to violate
this to violate the Fourth Amendment
weakens all of our protections and
that's why I think this is a much bigger
case than just Ross one of the concerns
that the defense has is that the NSA was
pursuing a kind of parallel construction
explain what parallel construction is
and why it raises real concerns from
what I understand parallel construction
relies on information that is procured
by the NSA illegally so it can't be
revealed and then they construct an
investigation that's not real but it's
an explanation of how they found the
target that is not actually how they
found it so that would be something like
the NSA it goes you know finds the
server in Iceland or whatever or they
you know the DEA or some other federal
law enforcement agency gets information
from the NSA and then they create a
false story that would put it within the
realm of a legal kind of investigation
yeah old-fashioned detective work
brothers yeah yeah right now okay and I
guess it's also this goes back to that
question of the government kind of
trying to treat the Internet differently
than you know kind of established real
you know real empirical reality is the
idea that if they you know because
there's no they're there they can be
everywhere without following the same
kind of judicial processes well the
Supreme Court has proven that they do
not agree you know recently Reilly
versus California with an illegal search
of a cell phone yeah so one of the other
things that you talked about the case
mattering about is that you know in this
and through all of the discussion and
the discourse around it the government
and many people in the media who talk
about it or what not you know the
government is equating interest in like
a desire for privacy
with criminal intent talk a little bit
about that and why that matters well
from what I understand in their response
to the motions they said that if you use
tor for example you which is short for
The Onion Router and it's a an encrypted
web serving process or community online
communications process that was actually
partly developed by the government to
help dissidents in repressive regimes so
it's ironic that you know if you're
using tor now you're immediately suspect
of doing something wrong exactly and so
it's really saying that wanting privacy
that you don't have a right maybe
there's lots of reasons why you might
want privacy and so that seems to me
it's again expansive as far as what they
are doing here this appears to be a case
where there the federal government is
trying to expand money-laundering or
this would be the first place where they
would be able to kind of extend
money-laundering crimes or criminal
statutes to digital currency because
there's a lot of Bitcoin involved here
and your son was found or his alleged to
have had hundreds of bitcoins which his
lawyer has actually also asked for back
how does expanding money laundering
statutes the digital currency you know
why should that worry us well I guess it
depends on what the definition of money
is and that's this big fight the
government's having with itself and and
by that you mean earlier this year the
IRS actually ruled that Bitcoin is not
money property it's property and so can
be taxed transacted it's more like
stocks which you can you can own but
then you get tax on the the appreciated
value right and and FinCEN said it's not
legal tender in any jurisdiction but
then the prosecution what to me is
concerning about what they're saying is
everything should be funds forget
digital currency everything barter you
know at porcfest people were trading
eggs for someone made the point that
we're trading eggs for whatever and
bread is that funds no any exchangeable
property well of course this this
expands the money laundering liability
of people and creates a home
more criminals just like a whole new
class of criminals with website hosts is
this a new class of criminal now a
website host if someone does something
on their site that is illegitimate he
was also charged originally or not
charged but among the things that were
brought to bear was with setting up or
conspiring to commit six murders can you
talk a little bit about that and the
role that that charge which is not what
he's on trial now for how did that play
into the way that he's been treated by
the federal government correct at his
bail hearing the federal government used
those murder-for-hire allegations to
deny him bail saying he was dangerous
which if you knew Ross is the most
absurd allegation ever he and so then
two and a half months later Sarah and
Turner the prosecutor did not indict him
for one single murder-for-hire charge
even though he used it to deny him bail
so there were six murder-for-hire
charges and this is when he was picked
up or he was arrested last October in
2013 that was part of the story is that
he had been a kind of genial computer
hacker or programmer kind of layabout
nice guy who had transformed himself
into the sinister dark net dark web Silk
Road operator who was running an
operation that in 2013 had something
like one point two billion dollars in
illicit trade going on and that he was
hiring people to kill people he thought
were threats to his empire yeah they
well they didn't but they didn't indict
him for that in New York who is in
charge of the case right now so five out
of six of those charges are now
uncharged crime which does not require
proof and actually the recent motions
are saying these need to be taken out of
here there a mention and they're
prejudicial to the jury right there is a
final sixth one that is in Maryland
that's just kind of been there since
October I'm not sure what's going to
happen with that frankly I don't know
it's just sitting there in a long New
York Times Magazine story or earlier
this year Ross was described
among other things the title was Eagle
Scout idealist drug trafficker question
mark he was described among other things
as a libertarian what you know what are
what were his political beliefs
do you share them and where did they
arise from yeah well and that brings up
a First Amendment issue in the
indictment actually because they are
going and it's brought up in the motions
as they're going back pre Silk Road to
his Facebook and other postings and
using his political and economic views
against him which I think implicates the
First Amendment you know I don't know I
can't really speak to that very well I
mean I know that he's written about it
and that he was interested in the von
Mises Institute and as you know so
that's what about your yourself and your
husband and your family I mean dealing
with this how has this affected your you
know your kind of belief in government
institutions and the ability of you know
of the courts to act fairly and wisely
well you know I am a believer in the
Constitution I think it's a you know
inspired document and I it's very
disturbing to me to see it abused and I
think that that's what's happening here
I feel like the Bill of Rights is on
trial as much as Ross is and it's very
concerning but actually that concern
kind of fuels my energy because and I am
fighting for my son of course but it is
bigger than Ross and bigger than a
website I think one website is by far
less dangerous than the government
trampling on our rule of law and the
Constitution I think that is very
alarming and to see it up close and
personal the way I am makes it very real
and I think it's despite I think the
defendant the allegations in this case
are secondary I know they're
controversial I much of it cannot be
defended in terms of you know people's
morality or whatever but it's what's
really important here and what's
dangerous here is how the government is
operating and that is something that
I've really opened my eyes to how do you
feel that the treatment
of the the story and of your story and
of your son story has been in the media
so far I mean you've talked about Forbes
has done a lot of sympathetic coverage
and it coverage that sensitive to many
of the issues raised the New York Times
Magazine story really seem to you know
come down very heavily on the idea that
the the feds had gotten their man and
that your son had become this you know
Dread Pirate Roberts how do you how
important is the media coverage Jim
where do you see it falling yeah I mean
sensationalistic coverage I guess sells
more copies I would say that the
majority or many are disappointing from
to me they just have tried and convicted
Ross already
they don't use alleged as you very
kindly did and responsibly they and I
sometimes will tweet them or message say
hey how about using alleged he has not
been convicted we have a presumption of
innocence in this country and it's hurt
it's hurt his reputation and it
certainly is suppressed fundraising I
understand people's reaction to it the
fact that they have not indicted him for
it why not if you have the evidence why
not and that to me kept but the media
doesn't really talk about it that much
the trial is going to last four to six
weeks by the estimates I've read what
you know does that sound about right to
you and what is you know what's the
worst outcome that can happen what kind
of what kind of sentencing is Ross
facing if if he's found guilty on all
charges right um time frame is / again
estimated it sounds about right
he's facing what would add up to be his
life there's mandatory minimums which we
can talk about those some time but add
it all up and you know who's face how
was he in consequence how is he holding
up through all of this because he's been
in prison now for our jail for ten
months so mm-hmm Ross is a very strong
person he's very resilient and he does
have a big-picture outlook on things and
um he's holding up as well as can be
expected I would say bet people have
commented you know probably better than
most he tries to keep a positive
attitude be a good
force in the prison he had it was
conducting a physics class a yoga class
he he is a very positive person however
it is very challenging now he's working
on discovery when he's allowed to have
access to it and that's very grueling
under difficult circumstances but he's
he's persevering where are the most
interesting allies that you found and
kind of talking about the larger issues
of the cases and then are there any
people who you would have expected to be
you know reaching out or being allies in
this who have just disappointed you well
we've had a lot of anonymous donors
through Bitcoin which would be expected
Roger ver came out with a retweet
campaign that was very supportive and
very helpful where he's going to be
donating a substantial amount to our
fund over time I explained who he is
well I guess he's the Bitcoin Jesus
Bitcoin evangelist and angel investor
and a major figure in the Bitcoin world
but he's been supportive and there's
been other people who care about freedom
and the larger issues here beyond the
details and how the electronic the
Electronic Frontier Foundation has been
has been supportive as I read they have
I mean from the beginning I talked to
people there who helped us find Joshua
Dre tell and he's conferred with them a
lot and yes they are supportive where is
the best place to for more information
on the case where should people go yeah
we have a website free Ross org and has
information on the case ways to donate
ways to contact us we definitely need
help with donations as well as you know
information advice contacts all that
kind of thing we were small we were
fighting a big fight and we really need
help well we will leave it there Thank
You Lynn ohlbrecht Lynn ohlbrecht is
going is the mother of Ross Ulbricht who
is facing trial in November on charges
of running Silk Road and being Dread
Pirate Roberts the outcome
will affect him if he's found guilty on
every all of the charges he's it's an
effective license and it may well affect
the outcome of the internet and the ways
in which we deal with things in in
cyberspace for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie
[Music]
you